(Tywin): As Aerys Targaryen's behavior
grew more and more erratic,
the task of ruling the Seven Kingdoms
fell to me, Tywin Lannister.
I had served Aerys for nearly 20 years
and as a result the realm had prospered.
The royal coffers were full,
the land was at peace.
But Aerys grew increasingly hostile -
jealous of the success many credited to me.
My power and influence unnerved him.
The captain of my personal guard,
Ser llyn Payne,
was once overheard
making offhand comments
regarding who was
the true ruler of Westeros.
When the king was given this information,
he had llyn Payne's tongue
ripped out with hot pincers.
It was my desire to unite the Houses
of Lannister and Targaryen
through marriage.
My daughter, Cersei, would marry
Aerys' eldest son, Prince Rhaegar.
Such a union made perfect sense
for all parties.
However, Aerys' senses had begun
to leave him quite some time earlier.
Instead of uniting the royal family
with its most loyal and powerful ally,
Aerys chose instead to insult my family,
indicating that such a match
was beneath Rhaegar.
Instead, he chose Elia Martell of Dorne
to be Rhaegar's wife.
As if to rub salt in my wounds,
Aerys appointed Jaime, my son,
to the Kingsguard.
The Kingsguard may be an honor
for lesser families than ours,
but it is a lifetime appointment
that forces him to renounce
all family holdings.
This creates a difficulty in naming an heir
to Casterly Rock.
But Aerys knew all that.
I had grown tired of the king's
constant provocation.
Thus I resigned my post as Aerys' Hand
and returned to Casterly Rock
with my considerable forces.
When Robert Baratheon rebelled
against the throne,
Aerys grew fearful that I would
join with Robert's forces
and rise against him.
He thought himself clever, and
kept Jaime very close, as if warning me.
He sunk deeper and deeper into delusion,
paranoia and violence.
I've heard it said he became
obsessed with wildfire -
a substance which, once lit,
cannot be extinguished.
Convinced he had enemies all around him,
he wouldn't allow blades in his presence,
save for those of his Kingsguard.
Alas, that proved to be his undoing.